what's good everybody this is clouded
I'm Devin that's Keith we got a story
about a streamer sent his desk on fire
we got overwatch League where there's
drama again and it's taking place on
Twitter we couldn't be happier we got
another streamer who about $2,200 on
black $20 black and some guy got banned
for missing a photo of pokey memes but
on streams [__] man all right let's get
into it
so yeah over the weekend this streamer
was playing a groove literally but not
polka dot blackjack roulette I know
you've never been in a casino before I
haven't actually he was playing roulette
and he bet $2,200 on black let's go $20
black and he gets paid off and loses it
he goes brave red like Devin he's pissed
off
I mean I didn't deserve that but anyway
a bunch of Twitter beef broke out over
the weekend concerning the overwatch
League I mean you saw that [__] pop up
yeah the VP of the overwatch League he
goes on an interview and he says how
excited he is for the best lineup of
talent ever and overwatch that they have
this year I think from what our talent
lineup looks like this year we couldn't
be happier and in case you didn't know
the reason that this cause beef was
because people like Monti and Sandler
that just left the overwatch League well
they took a little bit of fence to those
comments yeah and while the overwatch
League Twitter was on fire this weekend
you know what else was on fire this
weekend which some dude that is such a
rough transitioning come on yeah this
streamer accidentally set fire to his
desk and well it's [__] hilarious
how can your desk be so attracted to
flames their lights on fire from just
playing with a lighter yeah I don't know
either
okay our next story is a little bit
[__] up the face of the kappa emote
that we all use in twitch on a
day-to-day basis well he was streaming
IRL in Japan and in the background he
quickly realizes that this woman well
she's either being harassed or followed
by this guy
yeah yeah and he immediately jumps in he
made sure she's okay good have a good
man ha he makes sure this guy leaves are
alone and while reddit they've been
uploading this story for days are you in
danger yeah now we're gonna hard pivot
from that wholesome story to the world
of eSports so we're hard or hard-hitting
from reddit and this awesome story to
shooting games yeah shooting games
namely csgo
where the blast premiere continued its
tournament-style circuit over the
weekend well the best team in the world
straw list that I heard they're good
someone's going there some would say
they're good well things didn't really
accordin go according to plan for oh my
god I can't believe it 16 and 12 all
right so if you're a fan of csgo at all
you know our straws is the best team in
the world maybe the best team of all
time this weekend they got too old by
complexity a team outside of the HLT top
30 rankings and they beat a straws in a
best of three for the first time ever
now sticking with eSports and big-name
people we had one hit what are you
talking about big game people okay so
Rainbow six let me set the stage
Rainbow six Invitational happens every
year big event for our six eSports
Canadian big player even bigger mouth
this guy puts on a track clock display
that honestly I'm just stoked to see in
eSports
why am I so much [__] with the game
you're playing wait G language honestly
dude that clip of Canadian reminds me of
the way that I mean you talk to me day
to day basis okay I don't think it's
that bad but you have to admit sometimes
Oh i 100% deserve it sometimes sometimes
anyway our last story of the week deals
with pokey made one of twitches biggest
streamers and a well lesser-known
streamer who took a photo of her and
well he just he kissed her ass that's
what he did so I mean obviously pokey
man often finds herself in the middle of
these sort of weird controversies and
with this situation he kind of brings a
photo of her into Microsoft Paint and
then fake kisses her it's all very
strange but he ended up with a band a
one day band that then turned into an
indefinite thing I don't know it's not
been indefinitely banned and now he's
made this YouTube video pleading to
twitch and pokey main to get him back
online
I honestly don't know what the [__] this
dude was expecting I just want you guys
to give me a second chance please just
look at my appeal please I beg you I
need it I need the saw I need you guys
you my everyday it's everything I do
every day and there's nothing else boss
what's good everybody this is Clara I'm
Devin that's grumpy boy Keith grumpy
yeah I know I guess he's not know I'm
trying to think of something to say